[Music]
for us customer service is key priority
so we are constantly striving towards
providing a good customer service and we
can do that by making sure that our
field salespeople have the best possible
processes to execute on
[Music]
our customers tend to look at their own
processes and one of the ways I measure
cost is how long does it take to get
something done one of the ways they
measure their customer experience is how
long does it take us to respond and so
that pressure to improve the speed and
responsiveness of an organization works
its way backward as they eliminate those
requirements then the IT team has to say
how can we deliver the technical
solutions faster and just so happens BPM
is like the ideal technology for the
problem having an agile business for us
to accelerate some of the edge processes
and really taking core activities and
orchestrating them across the
organization is really something that is
changing as an example we've actually
implemented the ordering of coolers on
BPM ordering of Google's sounds simple
and it is when you have 300 plus people
in the field is they constantly need to
know stock level what's available of the
different assortments which types is
available for which type of customers by
implementing the process on BPM we've
actually gone from a old-fashioned data
non-driven
world into something where we can
streamline everything that we do in this
so part of the results on they're
implementing the coolest process is the
reduction of back office hours we no
longer have to send out manual Excel
sheets updated with stock level etc the
consultant in the field can now do this
real-time that also means that we have
gone a significant reduction from 283 to
26 and a half hours of back-office spend
just for the kula process
[Music]
so in our partnership with Carlsberg I
think another thing to mention that is
really interesting is the pressure that
they have to deliver great user
interface for their business users and
the right style of interaction for their
users so it's not just about how it
looks but also how it behaves how it
interacts how it either improves or
impedes their productivity every time we
develop the process we have business
representatives as part of the
development with the developers by
having the developers and the business
representatives working closely you
don't have to go back and start
promoting it they will automatically
take that process back into their
organization and make that live business
is now embracing business changes in the
processes because what we're providing
is what the business law by having
processes on BPM that are very customer
centric we can offer our consultants a
better platform to execute the
activities that we have towards our
customers whether being a new customers
that we are onboarding whether it's a
customer taking over a bar from somebody
else or customer needing a new cooler we
can provide a more professional service
and a better customer experience